[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في مجزيل الاخبار قال الجيش
السودانيين البلاد تمر بمنعطف خطير بعد
قيام قوات الدعم السريعه بحشد قواتها في
العاصمه وبعض المدن واضاف ان تحركات قوات
الدعم السريعه داخل العاصمه والولايات تمت
دون موافقه القوات المسلحه وحذر من مغبه
ان يؤدي ذلك الى مزيد من التوترات
وكان مصدر عسكري سوداني قال ان قوات الدعم
السريع حركت قوات ضخمه في مدينه مروي دون
اخطار الجيش وقال المصدر ان القوه المسلحه
طالبت قوات الدعم السريع بالانسحاب من
منطقه تمركزها الجديد في مروره في غضون 24
ساعه
في المقابل لا قال مكتب الناطق الرسمي
باسم قوات الدعم السريع عنا بعض وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي تناقلت ما سماها مزاعم
بان قوات الدعم السريع قامت باعمال حربيه
تجاه مطار مروى واوضح المكتب في بيان ان
وجود الدعم السريع في الولايه الشماليه
وفي مدينه مروي ياتي ضمن وجودها في بقيه
الولايات في اطار تاديه مهامها
قالت كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان ان كوريا
الشماليه اطلقت صاروخا باليسيا قد يكون من
النوع العابر للقارات صباح اليوم ما دفع
السلطات اليمنيه لتحذير السكان جزيره
هوكايدو الشماليه ومطالبتهم بالاحتمال
وادانا الجيش الكوري الجنوبي اطلاق بيونغ
صواريخ باليستيه واعتبرهم انتهاكا لقرارات
مجلس الامن كما دانت واشنطن تجربه
اعلنت وزاره النقل والمواصلات التايوانيه
ناهيه الطيران المدني الصينيه اخطرتها
بفرض حظر جوي من السادس عشر الى الثامن
عشر من ابريل واشارت الوزاره الى تقديمها
شك ورسميه للجانب الصيني بسبب تاثيرات
الحظر على حركه الملاحه الجويه الامر الذي
دفع السلطات الصينيه الى تقصير مده حظر
الطيران
كشفت صحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه ان
المسؤول عن تسريب وثائق وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه وشاب امريكي حصل على هذه
الوثائق خلال عمله في قاعده عسكريه
امريكيه
من الجهته قال جون كيربي منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي ان تسريب الوثائق العسكريه
السريه انتهاك لقدره الولايه المتحده على
حمايه المعلومات
هذا وقال نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان
موسكو ليس لديها اي موقف بشان مساله تسريب
وثائق البانتاجون لكنها لا تستبعد ان يتم
استخدام معلومات كاذبه بهدف تضليل روسيا
وفق تعبيده
انتهى الموجز الى اللقاء